que vous m'avez tellement manqué mais
vague chéri
cette fille c'est mon héroïne
tu as l'air content dit donc je vais
aller surfer temps reflets dans l'eau
sert
etc
[Musique]
je veux toujours sentir ton contact je
serai toujours là pour toi quoi qu'il
arrive et tu seras là pour moi pendant
combien de temps jusqu'à ce que tu
réussisses à surfer de propre vague
houinato
reflet dans l'océan
[Musique]
j'étais promis que je serai toujours là
si tu as besoin de moi c'est à chaque
fois que je chante
tu as parlé dans l'eau à chaque fois que
je chante cette chanson qu
plus jamais je pourrais tenir la marque
dans la c ou tombera si ça me fait mal
de te le dire n'est minato est mort
[Musique]
oh la vache
à
[Musique]
et